I’m sure you all have had this discussion
with your friends at
some point…
Why are flat rents getting so expensive?
It
doesn’t matter if you live in Los Angeles,
San Francisco or
London: we are talking about a global problem.
Then again,
we should first question… is this an actual
problem or is it
just normal economics?
Whatever it is, we’re talking about a phenomenon
that’s
happening in all the big metropolises.
For example, in the
city of Los Angeles, the average rent has
risen 15% in the
last 3 years.
And let’s be honest here… if you have
a
decent salary, this is more of an inconvenience
than a real
problem.
But let’s imagine that you’re a shop assistant
in L.A. Even
better, let’s imagine that ERIK is a shop
assistant in L.A.
What would happen to you?
Even better, let’s imagine that XANDER is
a shop assistant
in L.A. What would happen to you?
If I were a shop assistant in L.A. I would
probably be
making around 2000 USD a month.
A 540 square foot
single room apartment in South Los Angeles,
which is a
very cheap neighbourhood, can cost 1200 USD
a month.
That’s 60% of my salary.
The rest would go to basic needs
like food and clothing.
And yes, I would have a hard time
saving any money in that situation.
In an ideal situation, you would only spend
a third of your
salary on your rent or your mortgage, so you’d
have enough
to live comfortably and to save.
Spending 60% of your
income on the rent means that just a small
increase in
prices could knock you below the poverty line.
And yes, that
risk is more real than we might want to believe.
Los Angeles homeless population hits 36,000
in dramatic
rise
But this is not the end of the story!
Think about this: here at
VisualPolitik, we always say that the world
is getting better.
We are wealthier, healthier and have better
lifestyles.
This
is, partly, because… stuff is getting cheaper!
Here’s an
example: during the 70s, only 20% of Americans
had ever
flown on a plane.
Why?
Because a Los Angeles-New York
trip cost 1500 of today’s dollars.
Now, this very same flight
is just 200 USD.
Thanks to this, I’m sure all of you have
already travelled more than your grandparents
did in their
entire Lifetimes.
The same goes for other goods.
Everything
is becoming more and more affordable… except
houses!
No matter if you rent or buy: you have to
make the same, if
not more, sacrifices than your grandparents’
generation.
Today, in 2019, there are people in Stockholm
living in 150
square meter flats.
In fact, it’s not uncommon to meet
couples in Sweden who want to divorce but
are waiting for
their spouse to find another flat.
Do you call that welfare?
But the real question here is…
Why are flat rentals going so
sky high?
Can we solve this problem with better policies?
Today we are going to answer these questions
but, before
we do, let’s take a look back at history.
SUPPLY, DEMAND AND…
THE REST
It is a universal and logical fact: the population
grows in
every country.
Just a decade ago, America had 300 million
people.
Now they have 27 million more.
But not all cities
grow equally.
If you’re watching this video from Detroit
or
Cleveland, you’ve probably noticed that
there are less and
less people.
Most of your friends are leaving the city.
And
where are they going?
Exactly!
To more prosperous cities
like L.A. or New York.
So what does this mean?
It means
that the demand for living in those cities
keeps growing
higher.
This is totally OK and it’s natural.
But here is the real problem!
If we’re talking about a normal
market, supply can rise to satisfy the demand.
For example,
let’s look at oil markets.
We told you a million times here at
VisualPolitik, how Saudi Arabia decreases
or increases its
oil barrel production depending on the market’s
needs.
It’s
easy.
They can increase production from one month
to the
other.
But when it comes to real estate, increasing
supply
means building more houses… and this takes
time.
Besides, the investment for a new block of
flats is huge and
the profit margins are around 3%.
And the truth is that we
need many, many houses to cover demand.
California would need to build 3.5 million
housing units by
2025 to close its housing gap –Extract from
a report from
McKinsey Global Institute, October 2016
But why do developers have so many problems
building
homes?
We are talking economics.
With so much demand,
you could make a great business with housing
in California,
right?
Well… of course you can.
There’s just one problem!
Zoning laws.
You see, the real estate market is actually
tightly regulated by city halls.
If you want to build in L.A.,
you need a permit that can take more than
3 years to get.
And all of this happens because city corporations
are the
ones who choose where and how to build.
So how does the
City hall know how many dwellings they need?
Mainly, they
look at population growth.
If you check the data, you’ll see
that the housing census in L.A. has mirrored
its
demographic growth.
And although it makes sense on the
surface, this is a huge mistake.
Because population is one
thing and demand is another.
For example, imagine a
couple who lives in one house.
If they get divorced, all of a
sudden, they need an extra home.
So, there you go!
With
the same population, we just created twice
as much
demand.
And the reality is that we have a higher and
higher
single and divorced population.
This is not happening just in
L.A. but also in Madrid, Berlin and almost
any other city.
Many experts say that the solution is to build
more houses.
Others advocate for abolishing zoning laws.
But, in Europe,
many cities bet on price controls.
Do you think these
policies are working?
Is this a good or a bad idea?
Let’s
have a look, shall we?
THE OTHER STOCKHOLM SYNDROME
Usually, when we talk about Sweden, it’s
because we’re
using them as a model.
Swedish people enjoy a large
welfare state alongside a dynamic economy
with innovative
companies.
Among those, there’s Europe’s most famous
startup… even though it might not stay in
Sweden for much
longer.
Check this out!
Spotify threats to leave Sweden spur startup
protest in
Stockholm
So why do startups want to leave Sweden?
Is it because of
the high taxes?
Not really!
The main reason is that they
can’t hire foreign talent.
And you might be saying…
Come
on, Simon!
Everybody knows that Sweden is very open to
immigrants!
And yes, they are!
But good luck moving to
Stockholm and finding a flat!
While we were making this
video, we spoke to a man who worked for a
Swedish
startup for a year and a half.
He made a salary of 2900
euros a month, but more than half of that
went toward
paying the rent on a 500 square foot flat.
And believe me,
this was not the worst case.
Finding a flat in Stockholm is
so hard that some people spend months in an
AirBNB.
And
you might wonder… why?
It all started in the 50s.
Sweden
needed houses.
So the social democratic government
created the Million Houses Policy.
The idea was to build
public houses for rent at very cheap prices.
During those
years, every Swedish person could apply for
a public house
and pay rent at prices equivalent to 400 or
300 euros today.
But things changed in the 90s.
During those years, Sweden
suffered one of the worst debt crises in their
history.
No
money meant no more houses.
But the rent regulations
remained.
So you either went for a public house or you
had
to find a place in an extremely scarce rental
market.
Basically, in Sweden they have the so-called
first hand
market.
Those are the public houses.
If you’re Swedish, the first thing you do
when you turn 18 is
apply there.
If you’re lucky, in 13 or so years, you’ll
get a 2
bedroom apartment for just 600 euros a month.
In other
words, what you don’t pay with money, you
pay with time.
This explains why 25% of Swedes live with
their parents
until they turn 30.
And also, it explains why this society is
turning from renting
to owning.
With low rates for mortgages, most Swedes
buy
as soon as they can.
But the real question is… what happens with
the people
who aren’t born in Sweden?
What happens if you just
moved there and have no family to stay with?
Well… in that
case… welcome to the wonderful world of
the second hand
market!
Basically, Sweden believes that you shouldn’t
make
money from renting.
The law has lots of ways to ban people
from renting.
And long term rentals are forbidden.
But even
if you are allowed to have a tenant for a
one year contract,
the community of the building can deny you
permission.
Yes, you heard that right.
Your neighbours can say that you
can’t rent out your place or that you have
to kick out your
tenant.
This explains why, with so many restrictions,
there
are almost no available flats.
So, despite the great welfare
system, many people live in 200 square meter
flats.
But,
again, the worst problem is not the inconvenience.
It’s this.
Sweden probes riot in mainly immigrant Stockholm
suburb
Exactly!
The poor immigrants who have no startup to
find a
flat for them have to go to the worst neighbourhoods.
And
this is how they form ghettos.
And… yes, OK, I know that all
of you have seen those conspiracy videos where
they
exaggerate the gang violence in Sweden.
But let’s be
honest, even though the problem is not as
big as some
media portrayals, Sweden has a clear problem
with
criminality.
But we’ll talk about this in a future video.
In the
meantime, by the way, if you’re new to this
channel and
you’re enjoying this video so far, remember
that we publish
brand new videos every week.
So subscribe to VisualPolitik
and hit that bell button so you receive a
notification on your
phone anytime we post.
But let’s get back to our story.
Of course, this Stockholm
crisis could be solved by building more houses.
But, even if
you built 80,000 new dwellings a year as many
have
suggested, you’d also badly need to change
those renting
laws.
But now you might wonder…
OK, Simon… give us a
solution!
Is there any example of a city that solved
this
renting problem?
And the answer is yes.
Let’s check it out,
shall we?
VIENNA AND RENTS-FOR-ALL SYSTEM
Austria is one of Europe’s wealthiest countries.
The
average salary here is over 2,700 euros a
month.
And, if
you live in Vienna, it’s not hard to find
jobs paying more
than 3500 euros a month.
Nevertheless, rent costs are the
same as a way poorer city like Madrid, Spain.
For 1500
euros, you can find an amazing 860 square
foot flat in the
center of the city.
And I know what you’re thinking…
Now the guys at
VisualPolitik are going to tell me another
story about how a
city embraced the free market with no remorse
and lived
happily ever after, right?
Well… nope.
The opposite is true.
Basically, the Vienna council is something
like a developer
and a rental agency at the same time.
They are the city’s
biggest landlord.
You see, after World War II, half of Vienna
ended up completely devastated by the bombings.
So the
city hall paid for all of the reconstruction.
That’s when they
said ‘Wait a minute!
Since we paid for all of this… aren’t
we
entitled to rent it out under our own conditions?’
This is how
the World’s most ambitious public program
started.
Here’s how it works: 80% of Viennese people
live in rental
flats.
60% of those are public housing.
Some of the
buildings are from cooperatives and others
belong to the
city hall.
But wait a minute because we are not talking
about normal
rental agreements!
In fact, we could call them something
just short of limited property.
Basically, rent contracts in
Vienna last forever… even after you’re
dead!
Yes, rental
contracts can be inherited as well.
So, as long as you don’t
move, you can say the flat is yours.
And oh boy!
You gotta
see those houses.
In America and the UK, we have this
notion that public housing is for the poor
and it’s in bad
neighbourhoods.
But here, you can find public houses even
in the best neighbourhoods and they are amazing:
swimming pools, gyms, even saunas.
In some cases, you
can even find pretty absurd situations.
While we were doing the research for this
video, we spoke
to Vienna’s city hall and they gave us lots
of cases.
For
example, there’s a young woman who lives
in an 860
square foot apartment in the center of the
city.
How much
do you think she pays?
400 euros!
That’s less than 500
dollars!
But her neighbour, living in a similar flat,
pays 2000
euros.
Why?
He lives in one of the apartments that aren’t
public!
So just like in Stockholm, Vienna also has
two types
of renting: controlled prices and free prices.
And you might
be wondering…
How come they don’t have waiting lists
here?
Well, here’s your answer!
Annually, Vienna spends about 600 million
euros ($682
million) on social housing.
In comparison, Germany — with
a population over 45 times Vienna&#39;s — spends
about 400
million euros nationwide.
And now you might wonder… how does this
system work?
Let’s say that you move to Vienna.
In the first few years,
you can’t apply for public housing.
But no problem!
There
are more than 290,000 flats on the free market.
So it’s not
hard to find a place and the prices aren’t
crazy because
there’s a large supply.
Then, after only 2 or 3 years, you
can apply for a public house.
Depending on your family
status, your income and your pickiness, it
might be easier or
harder for you to find a home.
But, usually, we’re talking about waiting
times of no more
than 2 years.
Of course, as we always say on VisualPolitik,
not everything is sunshine and rainbows.
The first issue
with this system is that you don’t wanna
move out of your
flat once you find it.
This model pretty much reduces your
freedom to choose.
Basically, it’s not you who gets to
choose but the city hall.
And remember that your house
determines many things about your lifestyle.
But there is another issue here: the sustainability.
This
system relies heavily on just one actor: the
municipal
corporation.
This means that, as long as the local
government has the money, there’s no problem.
But they
just need one crisis and there will be no
more houses.
And,
since there aren’t many private developers
because there
are no incentives, they could easily end up
with a housing
shortage situation.
And this would lead to a lot of problems.
But we have to admit that, so far, this model
seems to be
working.
So the question now is…
Would it be possible to combine
this Viennese model with a more free market
solution?
Do
you think this system could be applied in
other cities?
Would you mind renting the same flat for your
entire life if
the conditions were good enough?
Please, leave your answer in the comment section
below.
Before finishing, let me give a special thanks
to MARC
SOLO and JAIME CHAPINAL for helping us with
the facts
on Stockholm.
Also, let me thank Vienna’s City hall for
answering all of our questions.
They were extremely nice.
Don’t forget to visit our friends from RECONSIDER
MEDIA.COM, the podcast that provided the vocals
in this
episode that were not mine.
And, of course, remember that we publish brand
new
videos every week so subscribe to VisualPolitik
and hit that
bell button so you won’t miss any posts.
If you liked this
video, give us a thumbs up and, as always,
I’ll see you next
time.